un nouveau train de sanctions contre
moscou adopté par l'union européenne
ursula von der leyen la présidente de la
commission européenne a annoncé la
mesure vendredi dernier alors que le
conflit en ukraine s'intensifie
avec un effet de frappe immédiat nous
allons maintenant présenter un quatrième
paquet de sanctions
ces sanctions ils auront davantage la
russie du système économique mondial
avec ce quatrième train de sanctions
l'union européenne ciblent de nouveaux
oligarques russes
l'objectif étrangler financièrement le
cercle de milliardaire proche du kremlin
parmi eux romane abramovitch
propriétaire de chelsea club de football
anglais et intime de poutine le
gouvernement britannique a déjà infligé
des sanctions contre le milliardaire
russe se pensent y ont de la vente du
club fermeture de la billetterie et de
la boutique de produits dérivés mais
aussi un possibilité d'acheter ou de
vendre des joueurs des sanctions mal
vécue par les supporters je pense qu'un
obradovic a subi les conséquences qu'il
devait subir mais ne mêlez pas notre
club a tout cela ne mêlez pas les
millions de fans les milliers d'employés
du club ne les entrées n'est pas là
dedans il n'utilisait pas celle ci comme
bouc émissaire du côté de bruxelles les
nouvelles sanctions européennes incluent
le retrait pour la russie du statut de
nation la plus favorisée une mesure
ouvrant la voie à des textes où les
importations des produits du pays sont
également ciblés par les sanctions
l'importation de biens essentiels dans
le secteur du fer et de l'acier autre
mesure phare l'interdiction de
l'exportation de produits de luxe dans
la rue si l'adoption par les 27 des
premières sanctions économiques contre
le pays a déjà entraîné un effondrement
du rouble
les occidentaux espèrent que les
prochaines sanctions finiront par
fissurer le cirque des hommes d'affaires
qui gravitent autour de vladimir poutine